dans votre solitude est ce qu'il vous
arrive de chanter monsieur cazals yang
évidemment je n'aime que ça mais pas de
moi mais non ce moment je me sens pas je
suis un peu fatigué je suis enrhumé
contre moi je ne me revient quand on
aime ou mesdames et hull au bout de ce
chemin sinueux malaisé poussiéreux la
demeure d'un troglodytes dans sage qui a
préféré la caverne à sa maison
confortable mais bruyante du village
[Musique]
maicon est candidat you may si on vous
met aux commandes a et b elle est
intriguée j'ai acquis sa politique
elle aura comme tendent il cultive son
jardin le grand espace vert c'est sa mer
de la tranquillité sa famille le
ravitaille une fois par semaine le maire
avoue vivace là aussi variable égal on a
vu la vienne si laval j'ai mal à mon
bébé elle est arrivée j'ai pas la crise
avec issa el aouda bouillon d'art et on
a merdé
là il va papa on ose à tour ne les a pas
il n'est ce pas
mais ces êtres vont mourir en boîte à la
verrerie watts org
je pense qu'ici pour occuper votre temps
vous travaillez un petit peu nombreux
sur l'exercice pour m'entraîner on paie
pour tenue un peu de mouvements mois
alors que faites vous exactement comme
ma coupure et 4000 de 4000 pieds de
vigne jugé que cet ouvrage sur mon petit
jardin fruitier
enfin j'aime ma tranquillité
quand même que je suis pas riche dans
les russes de riches je me contente pas
de noosa comme l'on vous a pas vu
monsieur cazals bien que je suis sûr
qu'il ya quelque chose que vous
regrettez dans le modernisme
c'est par exemple l'électricité mais
vivement à ceux le bien-être pour tous
c'est pas seulement que pour nous c'est
pour tout le monde et pour les campagnes
aussi tout la compagnie thé le meeddm
région et régions dans le canton de laon
n'a pas de lumière et anna qu'ils
allument une puce et pulu et le jeu nous
nous n'avons pas on n'est pas pressé
[Musique]
monde
tél
mais
25 ans mais moi qui avais
plus
pour l'instant il ya peu
je
irish à la 90e
[Musique]
non
outre la dette
c'est un droit pour tous
lindsay
non
on pouvait voir un point là
argent
[Musique]